you know what this town needs balls I'm
dead serious Falls ends annual testicle
festival is a decades-old tradition the
test FST is one of the few times the
community comes together for what makes
some happiest scarfing down cowboy
caviar this town needs a morale boost
and if stuffing Rocky Mountain Oysters
down your gullet don't put a smile on
your face I don't know what could
problem is the festival's been postponed
because of the god damn cult now I have
not go down as the cook who failed to
serve up huevos with a side of happiness
we're gonna do this but first we need to
get the testy feste supplies out of
storage the only fellow named Kenny's
got them all locked up for me at the old
bar I'll start getting set up you head
over and get those supplies
[Music]
we showed up just in time
one of these damn vultures gobbled up
the key to my barn look it's a long
story let's just say I was indisposed
you gotta help me I'm a lousy shot when
it comes to moving targets shoot down
those vultures one of them has to have
the key
[Music]
thank God for that listen the trailers
already hooked up to my truck inside the
barn
I like Casey no you're on your way and
let's keep this little incident to
ourselves yeah thanks daddy
I'm not gonna be just another homicide
statistic I'm gonna survive disgrace
[Music]
[Applause] [Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
are you ready to take this festival to a
whole other level all right deputy it's
time to boost T levels and give the
people that little extra fire they're
craving right now we serve our Montana
tender groins a lot of ways baked fried
boiled steamed cured hell we even got a
signature dessert nuts cream but that
ain't gonna cut it this year we need
something new something exciting we're
gonna put together a spread that would
make a TV chefs [ __ ] pucker three new
ways to enjoy that swingin beef shredded
roasted and brewed first to her simple
tractor mulcher and some fire should do
the trick the third one well let's just
say interrupts in a bull when he's
playing hide the salami is one of the
most dangerous things you can do but
that's what makes it taste so good and
you're done bringing the goods back to
me and we'll kick the festival off with
a bang
I can build my own levels
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
justice for all rebellion
did you get him did you get those meaty
bags of victory albey I think this
year's testy feisty will go down as the
greatest ever can't wait to pop one of
those juicy balls into my mouth
after I finished seasoning and
tenderizing these little musicals the
taste will be out of this world it's
times like this that remind us of what
really matters our friends and family a
community are cold you couldn't have
done it without your hero now you're
gonna stick around in gorge on these
cattle cutlets right come on go grab a
drink people shout out oh yeah
time to get festive
you